[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW BROGDON: Since the launch
of Firebase as a unified app
platform, it's been
possible to use AdMob
as a part of Firebase.
But what does that
actually mean in practice?
Well, there's a few things.
First, you can use AdMob
with Firebase or on its own.
Either way is cool.
Second, the only big
difference for the way you code
is how your app gets set up.
Firebase has a config file,
which the app needs to include,
and the dependencies
for CocoaPods and Gradle
are slightly different.
But either way it's the same
SDK for AdMob that ends up
in your app, which means the iOS
and Android API you use to load
and show ads don't change.
Showing an interstitial,
loading a banner,
or getting a callback
from a worded video--
they're all the same.
It's really just a question
of registering your app
and setting up the
build [INAUDIBLE]..
So, how to choose
which way to go?
Well the benefit of using
AdMob on its own is simplicity.
It's just one service.
The benefit of using Firebase
is, you get Firebase.
First-class analytics
straight out
of the box that include your
AdMob revenue and ad events,
plus easy access to the
real-time database, crash
reporting, cloud
messaging, and all
that other Firebase-y goodness.
Either way, though,
you'll still have
the same mobile ad SDK and the
same AdMob working for you.